( narrator )
25 YEARS AGO,
AN EPIC MOTION PICTURE WAS
UNLEASHED ON AMERICA,
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT FILMS IN HISTORY.
WE ARE NOW PROUD TO RELEASE
THIS MASTERPIECE ON D.V.D.
FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME.
THIS ONE-OF-A-KIND,
25th ANNIVERSARY
COMMEMORATIVE EDITION
FEATURES EXTRAS INCLUDING
CAST INTERVIEWS,
DIRECTOR COMMENTARY, AND
NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN OUTTAKES.
KIZZIE, BEHOLD, THE ONLY THING
GREATER THAN YOURSELF.
OH, OH !
OH, I'M--
HEY, I'M SORRY.
I TOLD Y'ALL NOT TO
GIVE ME A REAL BABY.
PISSIN' ALL OVER ME
AND ( beep ).
CATCH ALL THE GAGS, SPILLS,
AND HILARIOUS PRACTICAL JOKES.
♪ COMING FORTH
TO CARRY ME HOME ♪
YOUR NAME IS TOBY !
KUNTA KINTE !
OH !
I SAID, YOUR NAME
IS TOBY !
KUNTA KINTE !
DAMN !
STEVE, WHAT'D I SAY ABOUT
HITTING SO HARD, MAN ?
I'M SORRY,
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT ?
YOU SORRY ?
I'M GONNA SHOW
YOU SORRY, MAN !
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU SORRY !
( laughing )
I TOLD Y'ALL
HE'S SCARED OF ME !
HOLD ON, LET ME
GET UP THERE.
THE ROOTS 25th ANNIVERSARY
COMMEMORATIVE EDITION ON D.V.D.
( man )
INCLUDING ALL WALDBAUM'S !